gamer's welcome back everybody welcome
back epic gamers welcome back to doubt
the ruin everybody we're in the Thresher
hall you can follow behind us you know
oh okay this is one of the checkpoints
no I'm lost
it's like I haven't played the game in a
few days and it's like what's happening
oh yeah I remember now
oh wow this is so cool it is cool I've
never been on such a big team before
don't you have a legion of barriers guys
yeah but my dad forced them to listen to
me so they don't actually like me very
much this is so sad well you don't need
those clams anymore just chill with us
hey he just follows us that is so cute
look at him he doesn't even walk me I'm
still hungry it's like nothing I eat
here matters should have stolen more
money from the bake sale I guess huh I
cannot believe you did that horse person
I wish I was thinking of baking a cake
later
hmm what's the game you have to stop
making fun of me for one pass oh my god
[Laughter]
this game is so dumb I love it
look Susie a candy tree hell yeah hell
yeah hell a candy tree damn the last
piece is too high to reach very not
Susie I have a special transformation
for a time like this oh god what is
gonna happen really watch and learn team
oh my God look still farm share mode
activate
still mode all you did was put your
hands on the ground
hey don't act so jealous yeah
jealous haters Oh tell me what it tastes
like huh you haven't had it before
oh I mean I've always wondered what it's
like but I'm not allowed to pick it for
myself
why well you tell me what it is that
you're giving it to me I thought you
were hungry an act of kindness from
Suzie oh my god Sugoi desu nee uh-oh
candy joins the deep candy alright
alright
and he straddles along with this look at
that
so what's it taste like yum yum yum it's
taste like friendship what's that taste
like like my teeth are disintegrating
that was nothing that's actually bad
yeah thank you yeah but thank you for
sharing you're a good friend
well oh you too I guess wow this is so
wholesome I am literally shaking and
crying right now how long is this road
just walking along with you guys with
you guys just nice like I'm doing
something important that's because
you're alongside the Leitner's Lancer
our purpose dark nurse purpose is to
assist them it's the only way we can
feel truly fourth inning really
but my dad hates Leitner's he wants to
there's your dad seem happy
I'm not sure Wow there you go
your dad is miserable point proven hey
let's diss this weird purple stuff thank
you
you're probably just glad you ate a weed
family you didn't yeah yeah I'm still
boost from the juiced I can't read I
mean look I'm not from here and hanging
out like this I also feel kind of you
know happy yeah okay what do you feel
then maybe oh this is so cute all right
a lot of cherry trees come on
look everyone we can see the castle yes
that's where I live me and Doc my my dad
was that black thing emerging from the
top that's the fountain Susie if we can
get there you and Chris will finally be
able to go home
geez don't glow no grace laser let's go
all right let's go let's go anything
cool so I think oh my god are you sure
there isn't any another isn't another
way home the fountain is being guarded
right now if you try to go there um you
you might get hurt and what come on no
one's gonna beat a team like this if
anyone gets in our way all we got to do
it's Granta he knows the power of his
dad but what if you had to fight
everybody bleeds right don't worry
whoever it is they'll be cold on the
ground before you complete
but Susie what nanny Disgaea I think I
think I need to go when are you gonna be
back
don't go loud sir never none sir ain't
hey wait a second Lansing why are you
acting so we come back it Susie wait oh
my god what is going on a pretty the
lighteners are approaching the castle
get them never look at this look at
these move can they even hit me honestly
pathetic but ah Jesus you hurt me
oh alright alright zigzag zigzag my way
through my life look at that this is me
dodging my responsibilities oh damn he
has the power stance armpits Lawson look
at that stance damn hey what are you
doing huh good track we've coded them
wait wait oh it's the end of the soup
everyone this is where I should have
ended the episode I would have been way
more a climatic hey you politeness with
a go we were told to keep you in prison
for eternity too bad
whatever love to see you guys punished
oh well this is fine how-do-you-do isn't
it Chris that well this is a fine
howdy-do in person for eternity it
sounds like it might take a while you
are right
alright what could we possibly do and
Susie where's Susie we have to find her
Chris before she gets hurt or um hurts
any in with someone else maybe there's
something we can escape with in here
all right well if there's any if any
person seen in the video games every
time I anything there's always there's a
crack in the wall it's more it's more
wall okay what about this these shackles
seem oddly fashionable take them oh
absolutely
I run Hackl was put into our murse cool
we got an ion shackle Chris this might
seem like a bad situation I know you can
figure something out how about we check
here it's a metal door you rattle the
bars it's no use
hmm what about here life cannot exist
without consuming even the mo the mast
rings water perpetuate the cycle of
existence
sure I don't perpetuate you ate the moss
tastes mossy
whoever write this game is absolute
genius your Oh your HP which must happen
all right so what do I do with the
chains so Chris what did you find
what's all that green stuff two minutes
[Music]
you even put on press and check code sir
you look like a prisoner for life huh so
you can find anything well Chris let's
not give up hope just yet but if we
don't make it for some reason then I
just wanted to say I'm glad I was able
to meet hey idiots did you get it
at Danica's Italy Susie where are you I
don't know
present right in there seriously though
I'm mad at myself
i sweet-talked the warden into giving me
the keys
Susie really how okay I invited him to
visit the trash game anyway now there's
a person okay sobbing Susie right okay
I don't do puzzles hey how about we just
sit tight and wait for Nancy he lives in
the castle he's proud to come save us
why don't Chris and I just help you
solve the puzzle look I don't need your
help but if you said what if you said
what to do out loud you know I wouldn't
stop you Chris tell Susie what to do I
mean I don't know I'd spayed swap and
diamond
all right adding Spade no swap okay and
then add a diamond and swap [ __ ] its up
again
I did I've done it wrong okay okay I had
a spade and diamond crop yeah we did it
great
now come free it how I bit my tongue all
right all right cool that was epic
we did it guys and I ate some moss so I
think that value was that positive thank
you for helping her grace she
appreciates it Chris are you worried
about Susie she'll be fine
well regardless of how you feel
I don't think it would hurt to take a
moment close your eyes and think about
what she's doing now my god damn it
she's actually saving us you're right
any think about that oh I see
all right I didn't say where to next
it looks like the puzzle on the right so
maybe we need to find more information
on the left right did you say brother
sans well that's a dead end
best lines are swish if that's how it
sounds like damn not another one of
these maybe I should go back and ask
Chris and make sure they that's it I'll
just do it myself
[Music]
puzzle understand they have to say in
their sense the Leitner's can't be
allowed to escape especially the purple
one answer Susie
what are you doing here Nancy Grace and
Rousey are still locked up I I know I I
was the one who told my troops to put
you down there too to keep you damned
date forever but why thank you you you
wanted to get rid of us
I thought we were a team I I can't
explain Susie right now no it's fine
it's fine actually
you don't have to see giddy giddy you
know why did I give Susie the manliest
boys ever
why would anyone really want to be
friends anyway hmm Susie that's not
should it but dirty did you hear me get
out of my way no oh my god that's
hurtling did you not hear me man I tried
to warn you
so don't expect me to feel guilty when
they have to clean you up the blow oh my
god hey what is he what happens to
traitors
boom damn all right Susie time
Sugoi Susie time oh yeah
oh yeah maybe I should charge them more
TP
I'm scared though I don't wanna mess up
this cuz I don't remember last time I
save
if you don't get ahead of my house out
of me you got it
[Music]
doing good get it again damn what do we
don't see his hell he's not fighting
back shoot a while get sticker oh he's
trying to avoid fighting nice Hey but
get it ha ha ha
Jesus Christ oh look they go away
wait 20 fighting back so you basically
can't fail this fight I guess
fight me god damn it hey you think I
care if you just want to lie down and
dad he was making it easier for me don't
kill Lane sir
that is not epically alright if you want
to die so much then die oh my god
it missed thank God Susie you mixed just
move please
but but Susie if I let you guys go with
it then you and my dad will fight and
and you'll kill each other at least if
you stay here neither of you will get
hurt Dana
I won't kill me
bronze mean him will just dad doc get
hep piece of us down you know I don't
think my dad would like that hey Lancer
come on we're a team right nothing could
stop fighting or not alright come on
yeah yeah you're right we might as well
trying I can help too I'll go talk to my
dad
ripen him up hey now we're getting
somewhere
I'll head over right now Susie yeah are
are we steel frames of course I mean if
you wanna be few see ya
[Laughter]
so go how am I gonna get it past is dead
like that come on come on I'll figure
something in all right so that's why
okay Chris Oh Suzie you came to save us
I knew you had the heart of a hero Suzie
yeah
Petula christened rao's they joined the
party Chris and rouse a joy all right
Hey look at that fluffy boys come on all
right I don't get any string from
anything should I have gone left there i
right there I feel like I should have I
didn't all right this lift should take
us there now it might take up a house so
we should play some games
it can't be everyone hey Rosie you know
Lance is dead the king yes when we meet
him you think we'll have to virgin Susie
I mean I could easily smash him but you
guys I know that's not really you think
you're more of a that groveling like
total losers yep
and I was thinking maybe I could do that
to Susie
you mean you want to try acting when
Susie would be happy if you acted with
this and don't worry we'll be there to
help you
you won't have to figure it out by
yourself sure all right
so cute this is so sweet Susie doesn't
want to kill her best friend's dad I
love it
hey Rosie Susie are you still gonna make
those sad kicks
well will you stop making fun of me if I
have to I guess
then I'll bake you as many as you like
all right yeah like you can make that
many do all right here we are
well this is our stop
increase wait a sec you know I've done
it too real it'd be easy for us to get
out of here if we are get along a little
more so next time we fight an enemy if
you tell me what to do I listen to you
so we're gonna have to war and I guess
but you know don't get me anything
stupid
I'll go back to smashing heads all right
all right Gracie I'm counting on you
okay all right Susie joined the party
for real for real skies for reals this
is a big deal my gosh oh look at that
another save why who knows let's do it
oh sorry I keep
elevated to prison okay oh whatever
okay elevated to top currently stuck at
the top floor until someone rides it
down
[Music]
I guess we have to find this guy
rude Rangers came sparkling interview
all right so I kind of forgot you act
first
what retire a compliment
and we spare one I told zeusie the
couple and the enemy are you serious
what good can I say here about someone
trying to kill it
ah Susie if you're stuck why not try
saying something you wish someone say to
you you are unbanned from a ham sandwich
day hey it worked
[Music]
bearish lightning whoa whoa okay
all right let's try act again and let's
do another compliment that's funny Susie
complimented the anything your outfit is
not disgusting wow it worked incredible
what a team what an effort is that
pictures of Lancer does he have a sister
me hmm its sands it's the brother
Rudi's room yep yes that's a door
check it out wanna
a lot of treasure but two enemies I'll
[ __ ] it
we sold all of our beds to replace them
with treasure
my back hurts but life has never been
better
hey it's you you're that peaceful
Lightner whoa
he even tamed the Beast that was
tormenting us beasts were beasts Oh even
taught us appease to even talk to ya
have a cocoa diamond you got the cocoa
diamond okay
[Music]
all right we got a KOCO diamond everyone
that's always something what's down here
then oh but I thought we rode the
elevator upwards
[Music]
oh I guess we were in this cellar
alright let's go up here then
[Music]
whoa all right looks like you can go
down as well maybe we should try to have
yours Hey look at that if Jesse you open
the treasure chest
inside was clubs and which whoa a clubs
and which we got two items
castle by thermal or Royal Flush
currently unoccupied let's go oh
Oh poop is anything about dodge stop
Manny spikes they kill people there we
go
all right so there's probably a puzzle
over here maybe I didn't save did I
shoot so the worms have decided to crawl
after her nanny tocadisco yeah
vast fools oh my god
I am rocks card the our greatest
adversary now may have close to past all
those other wrist conundrums but those
were created by utter weaklings
now prepare thyself for the strongest
puzzle about life foil worms
[Music]
Bennett
lost frightened confused good toilet in
despair at the worldís last strongest
puzzle mistress puzzle how could we
possibly business
why are those still stuck it up on my
pillow
trapper hopelessly like an insect in
that roach if perhaps I could find it in
my heart to spare you should you grovel
for 100 years it's Mickey Mouse I'm
stuck at the puzzle what could I
possibly do
my okay
am i actually dumb like it is ironically
supposed to be a hard puzzle oh oh my
god oh my god oh my god that was
supposed to be easy
oh my god he made it seem like it was
more and I thought it was good oh no
those great
well it made it funnier at least oh my
god
sting cracks me out Lynn head heavy
blocked away quietly 3x okay I can't act
oh wait why I'm gonna Susie
[Music]
and he'll know Oh Susie it's okay if you
don't know how what shut up
that's not the problem are you sure all
right look wise guys what
Oh look wise guy I'll show you what this
so uh give me a rafting flirting work
hey get back here and let me flirt with
you
[Music]
oh he just ran away I didn't even have
to spare Oh oh my god I try to get close
oh my god I'm dying so much
[Music]
or I'll sue another act rail station
probably different Bend is they run away
anyway hell now let's see rouse they do
it I suppose if I it can't be helped
hey be your beauty is just transcended
your hair is like a waterfall of weight
um do you have hair er then you fell
awkwardly oh oh dear mate
that's not so easy huh what thought I
had it
alright it's alright
[Music]
[Music]
there we go maybe I should have saved
that every gun head average mine is an
enigma okay now okay
oh [ __ ] sorry okay that was pathetic I'm
sorry about that
Oh
[Music]
looks like we have a lot of enemies
[Music]
are these odd not actual
love the music
oh god is it another puzzle I sure hope
so yes it's time for you to feel my home
how about you oh god oh god okay what do
I do
run away I don't know face the truth
miss possum worms this time the
difficulty of magnitude strong see how
in Havanese thou feeble insects gullible
gullible worms that wasn't that wasn't
desist everything my ultimate puzzle I
have a waste better one right here can
we see it
[Music]
okay sizing the doors over here yeah
there we go
wait was that it is that a room it is
whoa what it says
[Music]
it's a giant faceful for parties
it's a boombox it's playing clubs music
hey V is the second party member it's
the healer she was in charge of catering
the party
unfortunately the cake she commissioned
was destroyed in a field somewhere oh
let us take your coat and put it in the
toilet huh which we don't even have
please try the baseballs yeah eat so
many you choked
do they eat sports then we can all play
twist dudes but just stay out of our way
we lose even by ourselves
what and the first part of member I'm in
charge of DPS dancing party soundtrack
great next little extra room appreciate
it let's to say
oh we have a shop here ooh welcome to my
shop you ungrateful worms what are you
selling her Alex routes a fragrant sauce
he'll stage a weapon homemade healing up
this music man we should definitely get
this school what if I add a nice carp
select our bird returnest a hit see now
in the dungeons worms
I want were that music that was legit a
good soundtrack I mean they're all good
but I like okay
equip
so we got four alizée and
Iren shackle errands Hackl
that's really good actually
[Music]
okay
seemed like we need to buff Chris though
[Music]
all right I remember you now undertale
you could only like whereas a few items
so good alright I guess we gotta keep
going I'm definitely listening to that
later
a bicycle is lovingly tucked into bed
what in the world just as I bought all
this items I feel like I need to save
okay so left okay and there goes away
alright looks like we're almost at the
top enough worms may have cheated admit
through my puzzles but in combat thou
shalt be scattered about come capes
[Music]
no what huh it's the enemy from earlier
but it's crown looks different it looks
the same I'm ace control any disc-shaped
life for me oh no it looks like it's in
pain it looks the same yes the control
crown is painful but I'm certain this
creature will feel it throughly when it
sees how much more pain there'll be 8
here he comes again
okay so how do we how do we fight this I
forgot
we bow right let's do Suzie's idea Suzie
you want to act ah that's your idea
well at weddings I kind of need you for
this one
that's fine Suzie I'll help you want to
apologize to it for earlier right now I
just need you to stay still grace we got
to get that crown up attend help me
throw Rousey at it oh my god
proceed okay oh my god oh come on it
alright so hit it still hit okay I
thought I had to hit it directly 20%
loose all right you throw again I loosen
a little
it's 40% nice ok so it's still working
as effectively no matter where you hit
it
60% lace ok two more and we're good to
go
oh my god he's so sexy
alright let's see it's visit tit poor
Rosie aha so cute
you won oh great I knew you couldn't do
it what
oh great hear us now now see that was
manly a friendly test of nine abilities
but but you what do you lock me with you
heroes oh my god
yeah what a great character it's my
favorite so far it's a throne it's it
seems to have been damaged in struggle
okay
all right looks like we're and getting
towards near the ending hey they're lazy
Oh father Lancer my son and you
dispatched the Leitner's as I commanded
no but I did even better it turns out we
don't actually have to fight her they
said they could just talk to you in
barreleye yes and I think you like them
a lot
there's Suzy she's very purple and
strong and where are they now
um oh great
how convenient hey it's nice to meet you
Lanza Nancy my son yes Father
do you remember when I told you don't
get too attached
you have failed they have poison you
with their sentimentality for yourself
Lansing they can not for you their only
goal is to destroy our glorious fountain
they are scum now they aren't what did
you say let him come
[Music]
you want me to let him go then how about
this I'll drop him up the hedge and let
him splatter unless you all kneel and
learn your place
what will it be like nurse
don't listen to her Susie Hill Hill
[Music]
now watch Lancer see what happens when
you befriend lightness Oh what your
traitor
come back in all right in there for me
who the hell do you think you are to my
people I am a hero to you
whoa what that Rick I am the bad guys
jeez it's terrifying
King blocked away all right
[Music]
talk let's solve a Rousey
[Music]
depend maybe I don't know browse they
tried to reason with the king you might
not realize it but this is a world ready
you don't have to fight I know we try we
can all find another way
search simple-minded poletik tables a
shame you will not live to realize your
naivety now perish with the pathetic
lightness you worship sorry my friends
and I aren't going anywhere
his will is changing talk became too
will you what what does that mean
let me change our ability here
the battlefield is running
[Music]
everyone heals ok and then what about
this topic
Susie tried to reason with it alright
alright
resonant glances matter so we can get by
without hurting you then if I perish so
be it show my son the monster you really
are all right you want to see what I can
do huh
Susie's will is changing part became red
buster what is that you that left us in
the shadows stripped of me whoa whoa
whoa oh I was not ready for that
Kings Mouse Babel in decipher ibly do we
have any I guess I can talk to sell yeah
Susie should defend and rouse they
should use
double heel
oh okay I get it I have to we'll just
use one heel for now on Chris
silence light bringers your very
existence against your are owned by the
Knights will I shall shatter your heart
to pieces your real exchanging talk
became courage you dare return too much
to torment us once again oh I see
Kings mouth babble indecipherably
[Music]
any more TV
[Music]
okay let's use courage
Brewed damage I see
[Music]
big on we have found fresh purpose
[Music]
okay thankfully I made it without
because I really think we need to duel
him okay
[Music]
they didn't really heal Susie that much
done for the night has this again really
struggling with this one okay could have
gone worse
[Applause]
[Music]
I need more TP
we'll use heal and then
defend the knight that pulls the
fountain from the earth oh my god what
is this
I was trying to get more TP his mouth
gave a bursar okay now what we can do is
defend again and then we can do rude
damage towards the king and you should
defend a small
okay so that's how we do damage I see
Roadbuster holy fountains whose shadows
are creating a new world our world Jesus
Christ
darkness pours from the pound okay and
now
[Music]
I think we should defend again even
though Chris doesn't have that much he
can did you do one more damage so let's
defend first then grow damage to the
king and brows that will depend hahaha
do you see now our new purpose i oh god
it's a lot faster
not ready for that
Kings mouth Babel indecipherably I think
he can do one more damage though I'm
pushing it
[ __ ] all right hopefully I won't regret
this
soon this world shall be blanketed in
darkness and darkness shall rule it I
can do this one
look at that nothing it came on the top
kings about Babel indecipherably now
[Music]
what's the glows hard you know it's time
to use the glows heart we had it for so
long I don't have enough TP then we
definitely will depend
[Music]
I don't know how many times we have to
hit him then you may see what it is like
to live in this bad
[Music]
I guess I have to use it defend this
round I guess
[Music]
nothing happened are you kidding me oh
my oh God
oh I didn't see those it gets harder and
harder huh oh I can't let Chris die [ __ ]
are you kidding me just cuz I use a
stupid glows hard
[Music]
oh wait we can still get him up okay
[ __ ] this is getting really hard
[Music]
princess back up okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
this is literally where all that items
have been gone if you keep fighting like
this like then you okay let's focus
that was close Oh what what are you
kidding me that was ridiculous
[Music]
what is check there
[Music]
I hope I'm not just attacking him for
nothing here
maybe we should boost our defense again
I'll do that after
[Music]
are you [ __ ]
[Music]
and
[Music]
all right so now we have more depends my
night shall not fail you are this easy
one
I thought okay enough is enough
I see I see that I cannot defeat you I
have grown exhausted from our long
battle oh hey you you're okay went away
light nerves I perhaps have been to Peru
the truth is I was not always this way
there was once a time when darkness and
light nurse lived in a time where
darkness could fulfill their purpose in
peace it would be a lie to say that I
too do not yearn for those days as here
perhaps perhaps you young once a right
please let us put away our weapons there
must be a peaceful solution to all this
okay we can have some cake come now
Susie I'm glad you're starting to
realize mr. king none of us really want
to fight if you can just tell us about
your worries I'm sure we can all be
friends mr. king
yes friends that sounds lovely
my apologies oh I'm not used to fighting
like that my body is getting don't say
another word
oh I don't trust him Phil he healed him
there you should be all healed up how do
you feel let's see oh never better
No
you
did I say you could get it ah
Oh spare me to hear mathletes
[Music]
what is happening Jesus Christ so creepy
you you're the leader aren't you so
what's your plan to laugh as you cast us
all back into obscurity
you can't even say let me tell you
quiet people piss Meena Oh get away from
Matt brain yeah surely you must realize
how exhausted I am play any hit from you
would kill me why not do it lightly
kill me and show my son how much you
really came yeah so what's your plan to
talk me to dead you stupid stupid
language you honestly think you have any
way to convince me not to kill you just
wait a second wait for wife for Lanza
why am I suddenly so sleepy yeah why you
little
you sweet little pumpkin hey Chrissy all
right I was close Susan I'm surprised
you remember my pacify spell hey come on
I never forget something I made fun of
you for crazy Susie I'm sorry because I
healed the king we almost we almost
Susie you were right
I was foolish to think you could act so
soft
this isn't our world where kindness
always wins isn't it's complicated
sometimes they're people you just gotta
fight but if you never let your car down
then I like that
listen just all be cushions and cuddles
you might just hurt somebody you care
about you everyone you're okay
Lancer hey sorry I kind of beat up your
day that's okay it happens
oh it's it even looks like he's having a
beauty nap that's good he seemed cranky
man you can say that again Lancer what's
that noise oh I actually came to warn
you
clowning I informed the guys you were
fighting my dad but instead of eagerly
volunteering to help you
everyone just caught the free cats now
they appear to be breaking through the
door to the throne room well that's not
the best Chris Susie it seems that you
must hurry to the fountain no Tampa
goodbyes huh yes of course no goodbyes
we're bad guys so we only have bad you
learned a lot huh only from the best of
the worst okay I'll go stop the door
later do it so cute Susie Chris if we
must say goodbye that am i I just wanted
to say I I really enjoyed meeting you
two in
hey can you stop mumbling into your hat
like for a sec can barely hear you do oh
I'm saying Chris Susie I what in the
world I hope I can see you again soon
next time I'll make you lots of yummy
cakes alright yeah sure dude let's go
Christmas
yeah that's uncomfortable let's just go
you gotta go Chris there's no time
alright time to go home
woah look at that
this is that bounty
don't know how but it feels like we
stumbled into there's no time to think
right now it's time to go Chris okay
this is stood in front of the fountain
he felt something strange It was as if
your very soul was below
[Music]
the music
[Music]
[Applause]
what is happening at the end what
happened why can I see hey watch it
I think you landed on top of us oh we're
back in school huh the unused classroom
and we get here hey Chris which is happy
like that wasn't a dream or anything
wasn't anyway as I was saying Chris
really talks a lot doesn't he
let's just tell Alfie's we couldn't find
any joke that's it
it's a yellowed poorly drawn picture of
a green turtle it's signed Alvin
worn down stuffed animal doors locked
what happened in here well man the sun's
already City everyone else must have
gone home by now yes alphys I feels no
it's like yes Alfie's will know better
than to ask us next time huh well yes we
should go see you later I guess
great let's go back there tomorrow right
what an adventure
yes we'll stroll back home
ring-ring create whatever you have been
doing I sat in the car waiting for you
after school for half an hour I called
and call but never picked up you never
picked up
you had your poor mother where's it's
sick Chris I'm afraid I'm going to have
to punish you
huh a friend you were spending time with
a friend grace I will make an exception
this time
you can continue our adventures a little
long but when you return home you're
going to have to go to bed early
see you soon man what a mom
quite an absolute man time to go home
the library Chris used to bad Susie I
was getting hurt now you can finally pay
off your family debt how to draw dragons
is 2,580
but he days overdue however grace I am
benevolent volunteer I am a benevolent
air system if you turn it in this week
I'll reduce your fine to a mere 64 23
considerate Chris
brains masseur it is working so I'm
starting on our project I've already
copied a bunch of pictures it's the same
pictures of a soccer ball 73 times she's
probably reading a comic full of hot
diamond guys and what though I love
reading books especially the books
upstairs you should really read them
okay I I will there's an animated review
oh yeah yes teens corners monthly teen
review mucousy cutie to this reviewer
had me Mewtwo as her first exposed
exposure to the series and let her tell
you it makes Miu Miu one look like a
dumbster with sparkly cat ears with a
darker store line and more mature themes
the second one treats the viewer like a
real adult instead of like an animal
that will die if it goes 10 seconds
without seeing a beach ball not to
mention Mimi's character is the first in
the first one is more stale than the
ramen I eat home at home by myself with
a light zone teams and others should
check out this dark masterpiece signed
the anonymous yellow lizard interesting
sorry I got confused I what happened
here look at that guy look at my guy in
there police chief Undine as opposed to
me directing traffic but all she's doing
is standing in the middle of the street
yelling get out of my way she's the best
huh
I feel really directed how am I supposed
to get past this blue lady I'm stuck I
guess I should just run away hey punk
get out of the road you're blocking the
traffic oh wait it's just a scores game
sorry I'm a little so we are ask her to
get her worked up lately
this job is so boring nothing ever
happens in this town yeah I just wish
something could shake things up huh you
got something to report
what there's a dark roll inside the
school
jerkin there's no law against dark
worlds anyway that's a job for the
school board oh we can't enter anyway
that's cool
oh it's you here are you here to play
the piano again the patients can hear it
well from here but I personally enjoy
how they can't
it's an obligatory hospital as a result
is missing whether the good keys do you
like my plane hmm you usually play the
piano a bit more beautifully is
everything okay you two seem a little
sick one see if anything changed dad I
can't just say that to her oh my god I
died I'd literally died Noel sweetheart
first time I laid eyes this is so weird
what are these characters I mean it's
great I enjoyed it I walked right up and
told her she was a hot piece of work
really yeah she slapped me so hard I
blanked it haha dad that doesn't help at
all
anyhow house dragon Blazers three beat
it yet
dragon blazes now I'm still at the Ice
Palace I've been kind of kind of waiting
to finish it with you day
no weather maybe maybe you shouldn't be
dead you should bring it here I'm bored
us out power her find you win I'll bring
it next step
oh it's great it's getting late yes I'll
better go I've got homework oh that's
the group project course bird guy again
what's his name nerdly it's bird Lee
he's not that bad day kick his ass haha
dad you're not even supposed to get out
bring him by the window I'll throw
something at him goodbye dad
bye honey oh hi Kris alright that's
weird it's a bunch of roses in a glass
container then ain't gonna work men
we're both beasts
Allisyn well jingle my gosh darn bells
look like christmas came early all right
Christie just give me the straight shot
why are you here did your mom make you
come here really you burn up a lot Chris
I'm proud of it it wasn't too long ago
you were just a creepy kid next door
now you're the creepy kid right in front
of me okay okay seriously you want to
chat or something so why am I in here
well they found some crap so as so it's
just some test yeah it's no big deal
nothing holiday came in I'll be out of
here in a jiff then I can go back to I
don't know yelling at you for getting
tangled in your own light display in our
lights light Jesus sweet eyes and she
Chris smart kind sweet couldn't ask for
a better daughter I just wish it wasn't
so defenseless scary movies bug Santa
Claus everything scares her and when it
happens two freezes like a deer in
headlights remember she used to even be
afraid of humans under the bed Chris it
was not nice of you to hide under there
by the way anyhow that's what talk about
being in here Chris not what's going on
with me just that in the meantime I
can't be there to protect her keep an
eye on her okay
Chris
even if we're grown apart we still love
your family after all we and me and ask
our college pals right
oh hey now the Azrael is off to college
you think he's doing any crazy parties
like me and your dad hey I'm just
pulling like your dad was no party in
your mother on the other hand she's
always supposed to bad going but once
the party started Yanks man why don't
she hit me clear across the room with a
keypad landed
I got smashed in through this snack
table and toppled everything tasty pie
though couldn't complain I'm getting a
little part of that sorry what in the
world
my blood is boiling for battle all right
[Music]
someone is coming up to the window they
just close their blinds
it's nice to explore everything else has
been slowly new we got diner man does
somebody play eyes me up eyes me up boss
Jesus Christ what is this would you be
interested in trying some of our many 24
pairs of flavors we got normal cheese
ice gravy double ice pepper noises or
Bironas and more stop on down at icees
paisa Oh God someone's actually here uh
iceice Pisa your number one spot for
piping hot phase sub paisa hey hey wait
a second I recognize you
little buddy it's me when a chat for a
minute before I lose my mind do you want
to know when as he's coming home you
can't tell them this but I really miss
the guy they be sweet to cruise around
town like old times
picking up for example chicks which as a
matter of course may not have ever
actually happened but one time and I may
have made eye contact with me while she
was writing me a speeding ticket all the
employees are outside that's great
hi yes
well his face is amazing well but a good
idea meet the rogue gallery blue ears
soft-serve obsessed no conception of
personal space keeps accidentally porn
slushy now me indignantly the Rory a
thankful absent due to the pizza related
injuries console a terrorizing customers
with the war chants purple guy man that
guy got a lot of action okay sighs it's
getting a bit much reading I guess we
can go in here well hey there haven't
you seen you in a while huh I remember
back on Sundays after service you and
your family would come in order to in
and order special course things happen
and then y'all stopped coming together
every Sunday you and your brother still
come in it ordered a hot chocolate and
you two sit down in that table in the
corner drawing shapes in the window with
your breath you must really miss him
here how about this I got a hot
chocolate
on the house hunt
whoa looking at my rug buddy you must
wonder what kind of secrets I hold my
secret is I put all my leftover pancakes
in this giant hat so for you two girls
that'll be crepes and cinnamon lanty two
bunny profits and a piece of firewood oh
I like the Bible there waitress here
maybe I should sign up to her now
serving drinks wouldn't really suit a
fire elemental if I got nervous I just
melt all the ice ice wolf does not like
ice in drink ice wolf likes ice to be
drink we'll take the special and do you
have any edible Claire the youngest one
won't eat anything it doesn't look like
treasure Jesus Christ it's sad it's sad
look who's walking around how are you
kid
great to see you again yeah it's real
nice isn't it especially considering I'd
never met you before
wink oh that's so awesome then the names
Saint Saens the skeleton I'm near in
time the name say what sir
we just moved in here so I hardly know
anyone why you got anyone I should know
better not my mom me whoa there tiger
he can't just jump straight into
friendship it takes time
all right that's enough time take this
call it whenever you feel like you got
sick I got Sam's number oh my god I'm
freaking out over here
what's up behind me yeah that's the
grocery store
unfortunately it's closed what a pain I
really wanted to buy something someone
ought to complain to the guy who runs it
what's up my teacher I'll fix ya no
matter came into service
okay
a but are you piece of tomorrow I need
some Alison it'd be great if you could
come up
I lived your snake story yeah sure Wow
you answered quickly huh
that's not good I'm a total stranger you
should probably hesitate one well I
guess I shouldn't complain huh what are
you what are we gonna do I'm not gonna
be there that'd be weird it's just gonna
be you and my little friend he needs
friends thanks for hey Abby see you he's
a little brother huh they're responsive
it the distance threshold of bones
[Music]
where did we live are you the human I
live on top of town
why my mommy told me about you does it
hurt to be made of blood
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god you guys are terrifying oh
you're lucky Chris got to miss class
without fizz it's not fair if I skip
ties to my dad never let me hear the end
of it that's actually not even remotely
funny yo Chris you survived Susy huh I
mean I never saw her beat anyone up but
I'd be careful like one time means snow
in jogging ttan were playing handball
and she just kept creepily watching us
from the corner then when the ball
rolled over to her she just froze solid
and kicked the ball as hard as she could
right into the office there untie scar
then and ein came out smiling cracked
her knuckle and totally wiped us at
handball anyway Susie sucks Chris ha ha
that's me what are you doing here Oh
Chris Chris you're OK I was really
worried when you didn't come back where
did you go did you skip class well don't
worry about it I'm the cool teacher you
know well you're not a [ __ ] ok well let
me know if you need anything wow what a
cool teacher
it's a saucer of milk oh did you want to
talk about something why oh this saucer
of milk
it's for my kitty Mimi she's a perfect
thing what does she look like well I've
never actually seen her but and ever
since I started putting out milk it's
been disappearing so I'd like to think
that there's a cat my cat
we should just head back home I think we
saw most of what you can see yeah yeah
[Music]
what is this dum dee-dum oh it's someone
here just a moment I have almost
finished watering these flowers here we
are turn there yes
howdy how can i Oh Chris oh oh I'm sorry
I forgot if you don't like hugs like
that
[Music]
well now made yourself at home Chris you
can help yourself to anything you like
what is this part is so detailed
[Music]
Oh Chris before you go
here for your mother our secret you got
the bouquet of flowers have a great day
Chris okay I feel like I really should
just go back home okay here we are
welcome home honey did you have fun with
your friend today by the way I just
finished baking a pie if you go to bed
it will be cool when you wake but do not
eat it all this time all this time all
right
instead it's a TV doesn't seem to even
be plugged in
butterscotch cinnamon pie
Hey look I flush the toilet
[Music]
tres
is everything all right in there like a
wash so never
[Music]
Chris what are you doing you did not put
a bath bomb in the toilet again did you
[Music]
Chris if anything bad happens you are
paying before the plumbing
[Music]
oh so that's our brother with all the
achievement and it's us being the loser
I get it now
[Music]
the wrong kid diner
guess who she wrote it Ben let's do it
guys
[Music]
what is happening whoa where's Oh
okay bad dream okay wife you Tyrion whoa
Jesus what is happening what
where did you get that from oh my god
[Music]
okay and the shadows start to grow and
the places that you know seem like
fantasy there's a fight inside your soul
that's still shining in the cold with
the truth the promise
[Music]
don't forget I'm with you in the dust
[Music]
to be continued in chapter 2 okay
awesome
I wonder how many chapters they'll make
this is just the beginning huh that was
said Delta rune thank you guys for
watching I really really like that I
think I don't know I don't remember how
much I enjoyed on detail but I really
enjoyed this game I feel like they
improved on a lot of things super fun to
play obviously if you followed you
probably thought the same way so look
forward to chapter 2 I'll definitely
play it yeah thanks for watching I hope
you had fun I had a lot of fun and see
you next time good bye bye bye bye bye